[Musica]
[Applauso]
muri ce ne sono di tanti tipi visibili e
invisibili che resistono che
scricchiolano che crollano i muri
raccontano storie appunto talvolta basta
guardare dall'altra parte
io oggi ne o preparate 3 per voi
la prima parla di spazio me l'ha
suggerita mia figlia di 10 anni mentre
faceva una ricerca
siamo nel 1961 la guerra fredda
raggiunge livelli di tensione altissima
a berlino
proprio intorno al muro usa e unione
sovietica vanno molto vicini allo
scontro militare alla catastrofe per
questioni di lasciapassare di persone
che da ovest vogliono andare ad est alla
frontiera la tensione sale e due paesi
danno vita a un'escalation che porta lo
schieramento di dieci carri armati
americani m 48 sul check point charlie i
carri si fermano a circa 75 metri dal
confine
l'unione sovietica decide di inviare lo
stesso numero di carri armati che si
fermano nella zona est a 75 metri dal
confine ovviamente non un metro in più
non uno in meno
la situazione in stallo con una tensione
alta crescente la guerra un passo
kennedy presidente americano e krusciov
leader sovietico pensano di abbassare i
toni
così i sovietici spostano uno dei carri
armati dallo schieramento davanti al
checkpoint charlie e qualche minuto dopo
se ne va anche uno americano va avanti
così fino al ritiro completo un carro
armato russo e uno americano uno russo
e uno americano per 10 volte poi
scompaiono tutti in quello stesso anno
in uno scenario così teso il 12 aprile
alle ore 9 07 ora di mosca dalla base
spaziale di baikonur in kazakistan
decollo alla vostok 1 prima navicella
spaziale con equipaggio umano
all'interno della capsula c'è il pilota
sovietico di appena 27 anni yuri gagarin
durante il tragitto verso la lampadina
ncha gagarin si ferma a fare pipì sulla
ruota posteriore dell'autobus che lo
trasporta da allora questo diventa un
rito obbligato per tutti gli astronauti
della soia poi spicca il volo
la capsula si dirige verso la siberia
sorvolo l'oceano pacifico e quando si
trova già sopra l'africa cominciano ad
accendersi i retrorazzi per fare
rientrare la navicella sulla terra
raggiunge un'altitudine massima di 302
km e viaggia a una velocità di 27.400 km
orari
i 108 minuti che seguono la vedono
compiere un'orbita completa intorno alla
terra per poi atterrare con successo
inaugurando trionfalmente l'era delle
missioni spaziali
la data del 12 aprile probabilmente la
prima utile per battere gli americani
che stanno cercando di conquistare lo
spazio come russe alan shepard il primo
americano che ci proverà tenterà
l'impresa il 5 maggio dello stesso anno
rimarrà con la capsula freedom in orbita
da poco più di 15 minuti in piena guerra
fredda gli americani vogliono avere la
certezza che i sovietici hanno
effettivamente il primo uomo non mandato
il primo uomo nello spazio e così
organizzano una serie di situazioni per
controllare e sono in grado già 58
minuti dopo il lancio di avere la
conferma che sono nello spazio grazie
una posizione di una postazione nella in
alaska che capta le comunicazioni tra la
sonda sovietica
e la base militare urss
mentre sulla terra si litiga e si sfiora
la terza guerra mondiale dallo spazio
gagarin commenta d'acqua su la terra è
bellissima senza frontiere né confini
talvolta gli uomini vanno oltre i muri
volano nello spazio e non li vedono
anche nelle condizioni più difficili
la seconda storia parla di prospettiva
questa volta centra un incontro con
alessandro baricco ai primi di giugno
del 2012
l'agenzia di stampa ufficiale xinhua
annuncia che la grande muraglia cinese
si estende per quasi 22 mila chilometri
la lunghezza della grande muraglia
stabilisce a rapporto e precisamente di
21.100 96,18 km che si estendono
attraverso 15 delle 22 province del
paese 21.190 6,18 km he una cifra
pazzesca e oltre la metà della
circonferenza massima della terra e
quattro volte la larghezza degli stati
uniti da costa a costa ed è due volte e
mezzo di più della misura precedente che
era stata stimata quando hanno
cominciato i lavori di appunto
monitoraggio della grande muraglia e giù
anche poco tempo fa nella storia
precedente parlavamo di spazio parliamo
anche di fake news o di quella che una
volta si chiamavano leggende
metropolitane cioè che la moore grande
muraglia sia l'unica opera umana che si
vede dallo spazio perfino dalla luna una
ricerca di santifica american del 2008
che intervistò molti astronauti stabili
in primo luogo che dalla superficie
lunare che a circa 370 mila chilometri
dalla terra
la grande muraglia non si vede per nulla
mentre dalle orbite terrestri quelle più
basse intorno ai 160 chilometri di
altezza si vede solo in condizioni molto
particolari
dal punto di vista meteo di
illuminazione ad esempio quando il sole
sta tramontando e le sezioni del muro
più solide proiettano le ombre molto
lungo
sul terreno la muraglia cinese il più
grande muro che sia mai stato immaginato
e costruito dall'uomo
eppure dallo spazio impercettibile non
esiste praticamente questione di
prospettiva ma c'è un'altra cosa
importante da ricordare non serviva a
tenere i nemici fuori di fatto entravano
da tutte le parti serviva a tenere uniti
quelli dentro a dare un'identità al
mondo c'è un sacco di gente che si alza
al mattino e non ha un'identità precisa
queste persone amano i muri e si alzano
volentieri con la grande muraglia
ho sentito il genere un giorno ad
alessandro baricco non possiamo
costruire nessun ponte
se ogni volta non mettiamo un mattone di
aiuto per coloro che non sono in grado
da sei di formarsi un identità se no si
perdono si sentono lo sbando l'idea di
confine e una di quelle grandi conquiste
dell'uomo che è costato fatica vite
umane sacrifici oggi parliamo spesso di
un mondo dove i confini sono leggeri o
li vogliamo leggeri liquidi light siamo
istintivamente per un mondo fatto così
in cui ci si scambiano idee tra persone
si scambiano cose
ogni tanto dovremmo riflettere sul fatto
che i muri possono essere la base per
costruire dei ponti che le identità
vanno rispettate e che per poter aprire
un dialogo
bisogna partire dalle differenze che
troviamo nelle altre persone i muri
possono essere utili questioni di
prospettiva appunto la terza storia
parla di disabilità ed è un regalo del
mio amico claudio arrigoni 18 gennaio
del 2011
luca barisonzi croce al valore
dell'esercito poco più di 20 anni da
cinque mesi in missione in afghanistan è
partito il 10 settembre dell'anno
precedente
una scelta per i bambini e le persone
bisognose di pace dice luca e insieme a
luca sanna alpini della sesta compagnia
ottavo reggimento
sono di guardia in un avamposto a bala
murghab terroristi travestiti da soldati
afghani iniziano a sparare sanna muore
barisonzi rimane ferito viene portato a
ramstein in germania
i medici americani e gli dicono muoverai
solo la testa tetraplegico anni di
terapia e di riabilitazione un muro dopo
tre mesi comincia a muovere una mano
nella sua vita sta per entrare sarà lui
non lo sa ancora
in afghanistan un marine aveva mostrato
la foto di sua sorella
dunque gli aveva detto bella ma chi è
quella di fianco e sarà luca la cerca su
facebook e inizia a chattare l'amore
comincia così anche nei se nessuno dei
due fa il primo passo nessuno dei due lo
dice nessuno dei due immagina cosa
porterà il futuro poi l'attentato
l'ospedale il silenzio sarà che non
sente più luca gli amici che scrivono
sui social forza non mollare lei non sa
nulla
si informa fa le valigie prende l'aereo
lascia gli usa l'ohio e parte per
l'italia vuole conoscere ragazzo con cui
ha scambiato tante parole sono già
innamorati senza essersi mai incontrati
lo vedi in ospedale e non torna più in
america nel 2013 si sposano e vanno a
vivere a erba in una casa domotica fine
luglio 2014 progetto touching the sky
insieme a luca colli alpinista estremo
luca barisonzi raggiunge rifugio più
alto d'europa alla capanna margherita
sul monte rosa in un'impresa mai tentata
e realizzata da una persona tetraplegica
usando una carrozzina americana una
specie di cingolato il muro comincia a
scricchiolare
intanto luca continua ostinatamente con
la riabilitazione nel 2015 sarà gli dice
che aspettano un figlio dopo qualche
tempo scoprono che sarà una bimba luca
pensa devo trovare un modo per
trasmettere le mie emozioni voglio
abbracciarla
il primo gesto di un genitore
più istintivo più naturale ma non per
lui cerca di concentrarsi e fare
esercizi per essere pronto
immagina e sogna quel gesto il 23 giugno
nasce la bambina la chiamano bianca e
luca la stringe in un abbraccio senza
fine il muro è caduto per sempre
potremmo anche fermarci qui ma mi piace
l'idea di lasciare un segno
anzi tre segni come se fossero scritti
su un muro tre tweet c'è una crepa nella
comunicazione
oggi scrive jovanotti nella prefazione
del libro che ho pubblicato l'anno
scorso e dall'acqua e da quella crepa
spesso passa una luce la crepa spesso la
troviamo nei muri e mi piaceva il
parallelo tra queste tre storie che vi
ho raccontato e tre dei tweet che ho
messo alla fine di questo libro
il primo tweet parla di apertura e per
me l'immagine della vostok di gagarin
che dall'alto in una situazione molto
complicata in una situazione incredibile
di tensione e riesce a vedere un mondo
diverso
ecco se vogliamo cominciare a superare i
muri
forse non a batterli ma superarli ogni
tanto dovremmo avere la capacità di
guardare le cose dall'alto di toglierci
dalla nostra condizione e di prendere un
po il punto di vista degli altri è il
punto di vista degli altri è il secondo
tweet
ed è anche la seconda storia mettere le
persone al centro la storia della grande
muraglia ci insegna che spesso valutiamo
i muri come qualcosa che serve a
impedire agli altri di entrare invece
talvolta serve creare un'identità e
l'identità è fondamentale perché il
confronto nasce dalle proprie
individualità le persone sicuri della
propria identità sono più disposte ad
aprirsi verso gli altri quindi ogni
tanto prima di pensare di abbattere un
muro
dovremo cercare di capire
che cosa ci sta dietro quel muro
l'ultima riflessione e l'ultimo tweet
col quale vi voglio lasciare è invece
legato al tema del limite quello che si
chiama il possibile adiacente che è un
concetto che ho rubato a questo
bellissimo libro di di johnson che dice
che spesso la soluzione è molto più
vicina di quello che noi immaginiamo
basta cercarla
pensate la storia di luca barisonzi una
storia apparentemente senza soluzione
una ricerca di un abbraccio che sembra
impossibile e invece diventa possibile
grazie alla voglia di donare e di
trovare l'energia per qualcun altro in
questo caso la figlia forse i muri
possiamo cominciare a farli cadere anche
quando cominciamo veramente a cercare le
soluzioni non sempre ad attenderle dagli
altri
l'ultima riflessione è una riflessione
generale perché ho pensato a lungo su
come chiudere questo speech oggi qui e
avendo una grande passione per quello
che scrive alessandro baricco mi è
tornato in mente questa frase
meravigliosa di 900 e di dennis rodman
td lemon novecento che dice non sei
fregato veramente finché è da parte una
buona storia e qualcuno a cui
raccontarla
ecco oggi credo che qua di buone storie
ne abbiamo sentite tante e ne stiamo per
ascoltare tante e nel momento in cui ci
mettiamo nella condizione e nella
prospettiva di avere la voglia di
ascoltare le storie forse stiamo facendo
già un passo fondamentale per scavalcare
quel muro e poi anche per abbatterlo
grazie
[Applauso]